THE PROBLEM OLUTION.
NI IIAST O
SINGLE REPUBLICASUPPORTER.RE SES
IN THE
GIVEN PROBLEM SOLVERS H
T DELIVER A
TE.
535 MEMBERS
COT 2 HELD THENAHIN OF WEST
VIIA AND KYRSTEN
SINEMAARIZONA.
BETWN E PR
MOALS WHOSE
VOTES ARE NEEDED FOR THE LARGERC
VOTE PLUS ALHIN RELEASED A STATD
.I CAN'T SUPPORENDINGN WE HAVE
SINCLAE POINLL O
RERDLE O
THE SIN,OWGH
WHAT HAR TO THE
PRESIDT ANMOCRATIC LEA
IS THAT SPENDING TRILL M EXPAND
FOTHMS
D MEDIINITION
FSA
SINEMA HD  TTHE .NG THAUST,
SHAR H DETAILED CONCERIORITIES,
AJORIT CHUCKR.INIMPOCEK, AIDES
MET WITH SINA
ONE DAY.GRWITH THECT, HI
OF THE
BUMARE PRAISE, NOT OUR
SIMPLY FALL I
CO EVENLY WEs.IN'S CASE  REPTUE
ATE  DONALD TRUMP WO
O Fs OUTNUMBER TH A
OF THEOPULATION.UST WH  THEO-CA
ELECTRICITY.E QUESETHER ERE REA
COMMISSION CREIDENT SO-CALLELL
OBAMA TO IDENTIFY,UOE THSCAL
SITUATION IN THEIUM TERM AND AV
BACK.BUT N THAT THE
ISY.TI
FR ODENT, GEORGEON, UNTIL OUR 4
THITED STATES ACCUMULAD
RILLION OFDEBTDMINISTRATION
EBESIDENT GEORGE W.
$5 $11 PK NADEUMPEFROM $11 TRIL
NESINALD TRUMP, THE NATIONAL DE
GREW FROM $20 TRLIILLION.
WTHEN
DECRMAY BE ANGRY BUT ATHE
Y AT .
A
TO THE LEFHE WN
NG A REALITY CHECKN
SS.THE ELECTION.
BIDEN DID.
WAAT HE WAE ST
MODERATE VOICE ON THE DEMOCRATIC
STAGE.
REMINDS M SOMETHING
CAJECTAREIL E CAAT PTHE
LD A EPENDENT THINKERS.
IME,
ERE TO JOIA I
P WERE
ESY ANCOMMIT TST
OULD DICTATE WHAT GETS
AND THAT, SATYERSO
GREAT DAY FOR THE COUNTRY.YO, H
MTHAS BEEN ABOUT
MOREIOUS ABOUT
KYRSTESI
ICHOLS, POLITICAL REPORTER
SIR AXIOS,ORROIS REC "CRAC
HANS, 'SESTION, AND UCHED ON IN
USE OF HER, AN
AT I MEAN BEING THOPENLY BISEXUG
GLASA
WINERY INTERNSHIP, THIS ARCEWOK.
WANT TE  E TO SIEOPLARHER THAT
DIFFTHER THERE'SYSASPIRATION WH
DO EXACTLY WHAYOG TO
HE- PA
FOR PROGRESSIVES
A IS THEY SAY, LOOK,SHE' A THATS
TRENDING BLUE,IT MAY NOTE TOTAL.
OULD EMBRACE SOME OF THESEAIGN A
AS TO ALL THE CAUSES OF THR
PPDON'T
THE
>> THERE STED AT DISAPPOINTMENT
DIFFERENCEWE J
MAHE COMUTPLAYE  PROGRAMS BY WA
I THINK THE XTERVOICE WILL BE A
AND YSH
>> THEERS
SENATE, RIGHT?
AND SHE REPRESENTS A STATE THAT.
OBVIOUSLS TOY  FORRE-ELECTION 0I
PRHEHERE'S INCREASING TALK
ABOUT THAT AS TO TRY TERREO T YS
PREMUTALKS TO AT KAYAO
HIS BOAT.
ORSN'TEE DOWNSE GA OMAC.A PROBL
PUBLIC.
SI'S
TRACK AND KEEPR
AT HERONA.
TO 30%. ATHEM
PUBLICANIN
LOOKING AT HER AS SOMEWHATA
WE CREDE-BY-BLOCK.
SHOR
UP ON THE SCREE
RE'S KIRSTE
THUMBS
Y N ON MU
THEATRICALLY THUMBS DOWN O AMEN.
DO YOU SEE SOME SIMILARITIES
SINEMA BECAUSE YOU'LCALL MAI AFB
PAY'S PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEEN D  I
.POINTED A LO HIS
FRIENDS IN THE MEDIARESSIVE POL.
SO, KN, ERED
THE CAMPAIGN IN 2008.
WE SAW HIM SORUT THE
N'AN THAS
UCNGAROES LEAVE THSSIBILITY
IF SHE FEEL
HEARS FOOTSTEPS FROM TARNE,
NOT JUST FORE RE DEMOCRATICA
HT, NINTRISTS THAT ARE REALLY
D
E DEO YOU HAVE
PEOP THAT ARE LYN THE PRRTY
CERIER GET THEM NOT EL OUT OOFAT